we are joined by cbs news royal
contributor aman amanda forman amanda
good morning to you let me start with
king charles iii
what lies ahead for him what do you
expect from his reign as king
first of all we are expecting continuity
this is a man in his 70s and he is
committed to continuing the stability
and traditions of of that his mother had
set but actually we're also going to
expect some headwinds
there has been
uh no real questioning of the value of
the monarchy during the queen's reign in
respect for her longevity but these
questions are going to come up and he's
going to have to answer them and he's
been known as a modernizer during prior
to ascending or taking over on the
throne so do you expect that to have a
role in his reign very much so and you
can see that in the slimmed down
monarchy that he's been talking about
it's going to be a much smaller family
that we'll be focusing on and although
he said that he's going to be stepping
back from some of the causes that he
supports nevertheless he will be pushing
those causes in particular climate
change when you say running into
headwinds do you mean that people will
then more people question whether
there's a need for the monarchy that is
right there is a strain of republicanism
in great britain and people people held
it back to some extent while the queen
was alive and those questions are now
going to come up and they're not going
to be afraid to discuss it in the way
that they were before yeah thinking
about that as we look back at the legacy
of queen elizabeth
how will you view how will it be viewed
both in the short term and through that
lens when so many people do still view
the commonwealth as one of the last
vestiges of colonialism
well it's very interesting because the
queen's legacy is many and varied but
one of the most important things that
she did was that she helped to reconcile
britain's very difficult past with the
present and she she started that off in
2011 when she went to ireland and she
offered quite a fulsome apology for for
a royal and that helped to really as
they say bury the hatchet and the irish
were surprised by just how much they
warmed to her and once you started that
it began and it's very important a kind
of truth and reconciliation for the past
you know i think it was liz palmer read
one of the notes and thank you for your
service ma'am i mean as simple as that
how are britain's looking at the queen
70 years how to even put it in context
but what is that feeling now that she's
gone after so long
it's
this terrible sense of being bereft
there's this black hole in people's
lives that they sometimes even know it
existed in the first place that she was
so present so strong and to lose her
it's like losing this incredible
stability and people are very upset
people have been crying and
understandably so on the notion of that
stability i this has been noted but i
just thought it was remarkable the first
prime minister
that elizabeth swore in was winston
churchill
who was born in 1874
the last she swore in was liz truss who
was born in 1975.
i and as they look back and and are
bereft and are very sad they can also
celebrate that's that iron-clad
stability that she brought
that's right
we often forget because we live in such
a modern age where social media gives us
news you know 24 hours a day every
second that as human beings we need
traditions we need customs we need
rituals they help to connect us to the
present day and that's what the queen
brought was that she reminded us that we
have a past and that it's okay you know
it's everything's going to be okay
because of the continuity that she
presented yeah i still can't believe
she's gone we knew it was coming but
the day has come yes amanda foreman
thank you very much
stay with cbs news as the world
continues its remembrance of queen
elizabeth tomorrow cbs sunday morning
takes a deep dive on britain's
longest-serving monarch from her homes
to her pets
and even how she was portrayed on the
screen